[Music]
in strange fetish news submitted by JK
Kumar awesome mother
awesome man with the vehicle fetish has
been sentenced to receive treatment and
probation no you go fellas I've seen
stuff like this
this is stochastic into the exhaust yes
he is odd did you do that our video when
this guy was like so he was a clot yes
he was like probably zipped up this
panty what I saw and he caught you saw
that that I was going usually he just
walked away real quick he stick his dick
inside legs awesome that's not even
comfortable though is it running or is
it like part okay because it's hot that
[ __ ] gets really hot and then isn't it
the whole like this big depends on the
exact but it's also metal that's
acceptable and it's covered in black
grease thinking that that's crazy
while he's sucking in there he was just
going on Hannah Oh uh-uh that just goes
to show that if there's a hole a man
will [ __ ] it yeah so this man famous
Jordan 26 years old apparently he has a
fetish that is called cranking oh yeah
and the act what it is it crank does
[ __ ]
apparently they remove the vehicle spark
plug wires to make the vehicle run
roughly it's like rev up like my mother
and then that's how they get their
sexual gratification out of just hearing
it rev well is he sitting inside and he
just comes or he's like setting off on
it that's all I could find out I was
trying to figure out some more or find
out someone Google born I did it at
Google in let's look at cranking and I
came across I call this like a different
kind of space or maybe it might be the
same thing I don't know but pretty much
what they're saying is that there's
videos of these girls like having you
know high heels on and the pedicured
seat and then they're just like doing
this to the pedal and like that gets
them off get them off like crazy yeah
guys or I mean I mean so they're not the
guys are watching that so I bet you they
go to NASCAR races and get [ __ ] not
all
that's harder so many people there well
I'm sure be like watching the rain no
this is boring it's a circle and the
carotids like 200 times I just wanna
[ __ ] and there's [ __ ] like what is it
like tricks are for kids buddy like on
the [ __ ] head of the cars it's going
around the circle over and over and over
I just boring but if everyone Jack you
lating of course well like a drag race
bam bam you're getting someone alright
now take it easy
who's like moaning run run okay because
I do feel alive like revving the engines
like oh yeah I got the power maybe it's
like a vibrator you know because it's
like a lot of vibrations so you kind of
just sit in the chair and you're like
Georgia Georgia you know you kinda just
feeling it through your body oh it's
like ecstasy maybe we just have bust
nuts yeah so this guy he pleaded guilty
to six counts of unlawfully driving away
in automobile one count of malicious
destruction of property and one count
breaking and entering in all my building
with intent to commit unlawfully driving
away in an automobile
he's stealing cars oh and then he
removes a spark post to tune in and gets
off yeah exactly so he's he's breaking
into these uh these like County owns a
vehicle Iser yeah I was just victim one
vehicle the vehicle I know what I'm
against this because this is like
vehicle rape
yes very much IRAs doing to the woman
are yours and then he's taking out the
spark plug thing so you can crank and
then he he does like this little Joyride
thing he's just breaking car hearts
everywhere this is bad my [ __ ] Nissan
what [ __ ] Lexus mm-hm
[ __ ] all not that you you know like
crazy about some guy he's actually
explode right that's not great yeah
that's not even crazy okay that is crazy
but it's crazy that he's a former
Republican candidate for Michigan for a
Michigan House seat
and so this is what he looked like when
he was running you're fired
look at all those [ __ ] crosses how do
we need so many Cross Cemetery c'mon oh
so that's do you thing is to homies and
this is what it looks like oh [ __ ] it's
in blood or hell Jonah Hill keep it I
know answer is out there yeah but you've
been arrested multiple times for this so
the judge is saying this guy needs a
treatment for his fetish
he just needs a makeover you mean for
makeover too
he's not going to prison or jail
whatever and he's not going to be
registered as a sex offender he's not
going to be registered and that's
[ __ ] that was a car raper though yeah
yeah but he's not going to be registered
I feel so unsafe like if someone jacked
my car because they're having a joyride
they were like committing a crime or
whatever that's fine but to come into my
garage and violate my baby like that
that's some [ __ ] up ass [ __ ] that's
wrong I would feel like I need to burn
my car after that because he just sexual
juices all over my gonna kill your baby
I mean either get a new one first of all
to baby now I couldn't kill it
I can't have it no one else a newer
babies are better though
yeah if you have like a 2015 and then he
busted nuts on it but now in the 20 17
years has better functions yeah it's
tainted it's no longer my baby anymore
yeah someone took a dump on it yeah what
you asking like you found out your kid
has this kind of fetish I put it on
YouTube I feel like it's um I mean I
catch him doing it and then I put it on
YouTube like I feel like if he was doing
it to his own car I'd be like all right
fine whatever makes him happy exactly
like I mean you know you go do whatever
you want in your garage right that's
cool but then I feel like because it's
kind of stealing from other people then
would it mainly have to kind of like
teach them like you can't do this
anymore because that's hurting other
people that's hurting ugly yeah because
he gets it through off of of stealing
like he has to have the stealing read it
he's like a rapist because like he needs
to do something bad and risque that's
just foreplay and it gets him off yeah
you do like with Dexter dude like with
his dad police officer he trained him
like okay you only kill bad people and
this is how you kill him so you don't
get caught that's why I mean like I know
I know how to do it
repo man because I mean he should not he
shouldn't have got into politics he
should have been a repo man because if
you are repo man you're supposed to
steal cars for the bank because you're
not feeling it you're just getting it
back you're repossessing this you could
check off and read the car as much as
you want and then give it back to the
van to take off the spark plugs yeah
everything you put it back in and then
yeah just work diapers it'll coming at
uniform ah he'll just look like you have
a [ __ ] fumble but yeah or just wear a
condom every day yeah yeah because you
don't want to wear like your Dickies you
know suit and you got this big ass quest
on the side of your left thigh that
looks weird it doesn't look good look
professional why is it the left eye
sometimes you're digging to the left and
if you're coming over there then you're
gonna have like this big as lima bean oh
my god I don't know what I would do if I
had a child that has to be like that
what about people man try to make it
productive yeah I mean I think I would
try to seek some sort of counseling and
then I would just tell me you know what
tell my kid you know what this ain't
normal
you're a [ __ ] freak but let's see
what we can do to help you that's what I
was it but just let you know this [ __ ]
ain't normal homey I think it got there
that's the real question
like he's ashamed of jacking off to
women sleaze like well I need to jack
off anyway and I can't jack off the
girls so I'm a jack off the cars I know
I wonder and I develop are like certain
fetishes how does that happen maybe you
had like one of those car magazines it
was a hot model and he was like ooh and
he's all jacking off but he got more
interested in a car maybe
yeah those [ __ ] five spoke words he
started looking more at the engine than
he did it on the girl and then he's like
yeah these car magazines that they like
turn me on oh yeah you like the babes
yeah yeah the babes bad - babe she cuts
around the face it's the babe out yeah
yeah the way [ __ ] models trying to
take a picture but then here they're
saving a good room hmm
talk - talk dirty to me I wonder if it's
like a special kind of car - like he
likes these kind of cars not these kind
of sound you know like foreign cars yeah
yellow fever maybe yeah were they all
Japanese cars hmm he did they do mention
that he broke into the body shop of
Chevrolet all three like I see like
white girls see like my daddy died for
he's [ __ ] crazy
I don't I don't know how like I would
feel if I started developing some weird
type of fetishes do you think you would
seek help or just keep it yourself I
don't know like I don't know what I
would do I probably just wonder if it's
like a some like unsafe kind of fetish
where it's like you like sinking a
broomstick up your asses I'm crazy [ __ ]
like that then I would be like that does
no space I thought in a thousand ways to
die but so is some guy I like fell back
really deep you know killed him boy
didn't do it safely
oh maybe if it was like I really like
[ __ ] blenders while it's being
plugged inside but it's not on you can't
get some help in that point that's great
at all if I if I got horny off of daily
household items I think to function in
the world in the morning I've tried to
jack off to that first like if I did get
horny by like copy table that coffee
table
I would jack off to that first so that
when I go to my friend's house I don't
start acting hella weird you're like wow
this table is new
is fine not into it I feel much better
you know what I mean so I want to
function in the normal world like so
where did you get this chair I would try
to jazz up to the chair that coffee
table whatever that daily household item
is first just a lot of inconvenience my
friends and I don't keep asking like if
I can I sleep over specifically in the
living room you think an orgy for you
haha so glad I never had any of those
things it's not just a normal kind of
crazy not the crazy kind of crazy hey
guys would you think of that video I
know you loved it so make sure to hit
that like button to watch more videos
check it out of here
[Music]
[Music]